[Aplausos]
en la vida nos encontramos con barreras
y yo me he encontrado con miles mi
primera palabra fue la educación
cuando yo nací no se hablaba de
inclusión educativa pero a mi madre se
ocurrió que yo quería estudiar el vino
con él yo de mi hermano mayor y fue ella
la que me enseñó a leer y escribir
estudié
estado
el torero regular y aunque no me iba muy
bien en matemáticas me encantaba las
sociales naturales deportes y formaba
parte del grupo de danza y de colegio y
el grupo de música tenía muchas amigos y
era muy thierry o productor
en el colegio empecé a practicar de
deportes como natación de todo tipo
patinaje
al llegar a bogotá la cita la situación
fue más complicada
no sabía que con él yo podía recibirme
así que tuve que ir
explicación especial donde al comienzo
no me adaptaba nuestro tenía 16 años y
visto un pañuelo dentro del grupo más de
40 años ya que eran talleres
para los más adelantados
después de buscar varios lugares que se
pudiera acomodar a los quería y postre
un lugar
que me facilitó estudiar
en el servicio nacional de aprendizaje y
graduado y fracturarle como auxiliar de
servicio de apoyo logístico pues yo
quería saturarme con mis hermanos
fue difícil entender los módulos de
aprendizaje porque todos adaptamos en
nuestra discapacidad pero con la ayuda
de mi madre logramos entender la materia
salir adelante hice mis prácticas
durante un año el almacén de hostelería
como auxiliar de ancianos
en los jardines también formada de parte
del grupo de anza y eso les permitió
viajar por muchas ciudades presentan
nuevo gota
mi segunda madera fue el transporte
a mi práctica tuve que aprender a
movilizarme
comporta el transporte puesto y fue todo
un proyecto puede pues es pasar muy
rápido y no lograba
pero en la ruta por mitificó dificultad
visual
por lo anterior debe entonces fijarme en
los colores ya que en esa época no
existía el sí y yo hacía para los que
fuera la vida cuando lo que sabía pasar
cerca de mi casa después en el cip o ser
ver números y así me resulta más fácil
un día hubo un accidente y tuve que
pedir al productor que le buscara otro
bus william le había pagado mi pasado
en otra ocasión en la que me esté
emplazaba el trap y de ello cuando fui a
bajarme en la estación que me podía las
puertas no se abrieron tuve que seguir
fue un largo trayecto
hasta poder volver a casa
difícil pero madre mis vicios y
acompañamientos
tengo el cuidado envía mi familia los
datos de entonces y la plata del taxi
que pobre
y es mi deseo barea fue el trabajo
la persona con discapacidad elevó mucha
dificultad para conseguir un trabajo
pues se piensa que no son capaces de
realizar tareas cumplir el horario o
tener norma de una empresa la mayoría
para verse necesitamos que una fundación
asociación con esta institución no
quiera postular a hogares
una vez logrado el trabajo en otras
acciones surgen inconvenientes algunos
jefes o compañeros que no entienden en
nuestra discapacidad por estar con
sables de ilusiones ni apoya el bersa
fortaleza en el año el año 2011
tuve la podría lograr que el remitido a
una empresa de café colombiano y donde
tengo otro tipo como de libertad ppl y
cosas del respeto del conocimiento de
vigentes compañeros y clientes de la
tienda
cada día aprendo y ya se prepara este
vecino capuchino boca tino de lado pero
lo más importante me siento útil
mientras pocos solos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y soy muy feliz
pero reconocí mi trabajo y vinculado en
mi primer año del trabajo como novato
del año y también vaticinó el campeonato
de panismo en la empresa
qué trabajo el divino siendo la
inclusión del aula social
social pero es por tanto y adiós hobby
de expedientes que me respeta y se
siente muy bien atendida con mi servicio
ya cumplir siete años trabajando en esta
empresa de café pero tuve que pasar
algunas dificultades para lograr
importante o tiene otros de trabajo y
tener la misma galicia laborales ya que
ya que la tradición no nos permitía y
malos tratos pues se quería que la
persona con discapacidad no teníamos
capacidad legal
ni podíamos decidir soy en nuestra
propia vida
una barrera legal
todas las parejas anteriores se sumaba
ya no me di cuenta de que legalmente
tenía lo que pedía
una marea en el estudio civil que no nos
considera sujetos de derecho ubicaciones
sino a actividad y pedidos pero por
nuestra discapacidad seguro
esta plantas la persona con discapacidad
no teníamos primer retrato lugares
tampoco podríamos decir es nuestro
derecho al cuerpo aunque
la propuesta del distrito cambia por dos
que no nos dejamos convencer a nadie
[Aplausos]
de martes adelante esto estaba la
posibilidad
teníamos de pensar organizar en nuestra
propia vida
en mi caso aún aunque tengo una novia
desde hace años que se llama no había
viviendas ya y el cielo mucho no me está
permitido pensar matrimonio y todas voy
a dejar
y esto hizo que apoyara
todos los esfuerzos que se han dado
para que exista una ley que nos dé
capacidad legal y 7 nuestros derechos
sólo ante dios estuve en el progreso de
la república de colombia la tica del
proyecto de ley
capaz de alejar de la persona con
discapacidad que busca acabar la
división
necesitamos
apoyos algunos casos apoyos que todo el
punto
necesita cuando se va a tomar decisiones
importantes
este proyecto ya fue aprobado en senado
y cámara de representantes donde fue
oída mi voz y podría la de toda persona
en condición discapacidad en el pasado
26 de agosto relacionado por el señor
presidente de la república y se compitió
en la ley 1996 por medio de la actual
establece el régimen de discapacidad
legal de las personas con discapacidad
mayor era
el 9 de septiembre hable y no tengo
miedo en la presidencia de la república
en la socialización de la ley y pitado
por la paz y la resistencia para la
participación de la persona con
discapacidad
el primero de noviembre terminé en el
pensador yo de la rama judicial invitada
por la suerte suprema de justicia para
hablar sobre el aporte y el tema en la
mencionada ley
me siento orgulloso porque en el pueblo
les dice la tío del estado colombiano se
escuchó mi voz y así ya contamos con una
ley
y este es nuestro derecho a tomar
decisiones
también por haber hablado ante poder
judicial
para que cambie la batería que tiene
respeto de la discapacidad y así pueda
aplicar la ley
finalmente quiero decir que todos
exportamos compadrea en la vida
lo importante es que nosotros decidimos
qué grandes son y si no vamos dejar
vencer por ellas
ahora es mi gusto
y para ustedes que también son sus
parejas cuenta
[Aplausos]